He said unto them,
here I pray you this dream,
which I have dreamed for.
Behold,
we were binding,
we achieves in the field,
and Lo,
my sheaf arose.
And behold,
your sheaves stood round about and bowed to my sheaf
and his,
and remember he's,
yeah,
the young one,
right.
And,
and also the daughter of the favorite wife,
which is another thing that's,
or the son of the favorite wife,
which is another thing,
not really working in his favor.
And his brethren said to him,
Shalt Thou indeed reign over us,
or shall dow indeed have dominion over us?
And they hated him,
yet the more for his dreams and for his words,
while there there's a shock,
you know,
that makes perfect sense.
So when it gets worse,
so you see here,
well there's the wheat sheaves bowing there and uh,
and then you see this,
what's going on here?
Well,
that's not the end of his,
let's call it grandiosity.
Um,
and there's an idea too,
and in the Old Testament,
especially in the stories of Joseph,
that if God sends you a dream twice,
he really means it.
And so I don't know if that's true,
although I do know that people have repeating dreams.
Um,
it might be true that a dream you have twice is really trying to punch something
home.
You know,
it's certainly the case that recurrent nightmares are meaningful and that
recurrent nightmares are associated quite tightly with decreased states of
mental health.
And that if you can treat the nightmare,
which is often quite easy,
um,
by the way,
then the,
some of the mental health problems will decrease.
So repeated dreams seem to be important anyways,
he dreamed yet another dream and told it to his brethren and said,
behold,
I've had another dream and be and behold the sun and the moon.
And the 11 stars bowed to me and he told it to his father and to his brothers
and his father rebuked him and said unto you,
unto him,
what is this dream that thou history of shall I?
And My,
and your mother and your brothers indeed come to bow down ourselves to the,
to the earth.
And his brothers envied him,
but his father observed to say,
well,
what the hell do you make of something like that,
right?
If someone tells you that it's like,
are they responsible for their dreams?
We don't really seem,
we don't really hold ourselves responsible for are for the dreams we have at
night and what do you make of a dream is like one of the things that you've
pointed out,
this is where he differed from Freud substantially is Freud tended to think that
the dream had its meaning because it's contents were acceptable to the conscious
mind and young said,
no,
you don't understand.
That's not what happens.
What happens is the dream is doing the best it can to express something that the
person doesn't yet really know and young thought about the dream as a
manifestation of nature.
It wasn't associated with the ego at all.
It was just like you have a dream and there were things happening in it.
The same way that when you walk into a dinner party,
there are things happening there.
You know,
it's not,
the dream isn't something that's subject to your capacity for manipulation.
It's something that happens to you,
not something that you do.
And so,
so if someone has a dream like that,
well you've got three options.
You can just discount dreams all together,
which is what people in the modern world tend to do,
which is a very bad idea because their thoughts and you shouldn't discount them.
You know what I mean?
They're hardly random as some neuroscientists claim.
That's absolutely cockeyed theory,
that random.
He like television,
Snow on a TV set if it was random.
So,
so one is while you just discount dreams.
The other is that you consider the person a liar and a braggart and a
narcissist.
And the third is,
well,
what's the third?
It's like he dreamt that the sun and the moon and the stars bowed down to him.
You might think about that two or three times.
So,
but it's not necessarily something that's going to make you happy.